The school of life is a youtube channel,
online business and physical school that
professors to teach people about
philosophy and emotional intelligence,
but unfortunately they fall far short of
their own standard to the point it's
almost offensive.
The problem with the school of life is
threefold.
They pretend to be unbiased.
They're selling a shallow,
narrow view of philosophy and they are
relentless profit tears in the worst
possible way,
but first,
who exactly is the school of life?
I say who because while many people work
for the school of life,
one man in particular,
the founder,
the main creator of most of their
content,
alon to Bhutan.
If you're unfamiliar with Alonda
Bhutan's work,
he's a sort of self stylized pop
philosopher,
but his works are really more something
like opinion pieces on life with a
ragtag assortment of philosophy
sprinkled in some of his works include
how to think more about sex art as
therapy on love.
If you're thinking that you already
sounds closer to oprah than he does to
aristotle,
that's not far from the opinion of many
others.
Alon is a polarizing figure.
He's in disrepute by many philosophers
as well as many book reviewers who both
criticized him for Lauren,
his books to appeal to a mass market
crowd.
On the other hand,
his books have been widely sold and the
school of life,
his brainchild,
both one of the biggest audiences for
any philosophy channel on Youtube and
Alon is important to understand because
he is the father of many of the ideas
pedaled from the school of life,
but now that we're clear on who's behind
this,
let's get on with the problems at the
school of life.
Number one,
they pretend to be unbiased and this is
what started my dislike of the school of
life.
They pretend to be unbiased,
will actually having a very particular
world view and perspective on
philosophy.
Here's such a claim in their intro
video.
What is the school of life?
This school of life and openminded
rigorous on ideological organization.
Let's hear that again and open minded
and rigorous on ideological
organization,
openminded and an ideological,
but then when you click on their videos,
all you get is a constant stream of
alonzo values and thoughts without even
the slightest critique of them as an
example are open minded and an
ideological organization has this to say
about children.
It's almost a biological level.
Kids will kill the relationship that
produce them.
I don't know where Alon gets this
massive chip on his shoulder,
but not all kids are harbingers of doom
to a relationship,
but maintaining the status of being
unbiased.
Alon also manages to quash several
millennia of debate with this nuance,
an ideological statement about religion,
what religion teachers isn't about
what's true,
but about what many of us here on earth
desperately wanted to be true.
Openminded,
rigorous on ideological organization.
Religious beliefs are of course
technically falls,
but that coming from a very tender and
vulnerable place which needs our
empathy.
Of course atheists are technically
right,
but there's no point getting mad and by
the apparent irrationality of the
religious
pack up your bags,
boys,
Alon and the crack team of philosophers.
At the school of life,
have it all figured out and I wanted to
be clear,
I don't have a problem with the school
of life producing a video like this.
They're welcome to their opinion,
but don't tell your viewer that you're
open minded and an ideological so while
the school of life claims to be
unbiased,
they make videos.
They give a singular,
narrow ideological answer to some of the
most important philosophical questions.
At their best.
This means they're self deceptive and
saying that they are unbiased.
At worst,
they are deliberately misleading their
audience in order to gain the appearance
of objectivity,
and in this one point I think alon just
might be a philosopher in the definition
of nature himself.
Nisha had this to say about philosophers
and their prejudices.
Philosophers,
they're all advocates who do not wish to
be regarded as such.
Generally astute defenders also have
their prejudices which they dove is true
problem to.
They're selling bad philosophy.
They do this by delivering a shallow
reductionist viewpoint that lets people
stoke a sense of pseudo intellectual ism
and spares them from the pains of
contradiction to be found in many
worldviews.
Many defenders of the school of life
might say that they are best viewed as
an introduction to philosophy and a
seven minute video on plato can't
possibly be expected to carry everything
that he said and I would agree with you,
but that's not what bothers me about the
school of life's work.
The problem is instead of conveying a
true,
albeit simplistic view of the
philosophers ideas,
many times instead they extract a
philosopher's ideas and mesh them into
their viewpoint until they resemble some
sort of self help.
Nonsense,
which is not at all how the philosophers
work was meant to be taken.
For example,
with Plato,
they can turn them into a dating coach
offering the following relationship
advice.
Second big idea.
Let your lover change you.
That sounds weird.
If you think that love means finding
someone who wants you just the way you
are in the symposium,
Plato's play about a dinner party where
a group of friends drink too much and
get talking about love,
sex,
and relationships.
Plato says,
True Love is admiration,
and on the surface it seems like,
well,
yeah,
maybe plato did say that,
but the point is they're totally
contorting the author's work and
achievement played his major
contribution to philosophy or his
theories of forum,
dialectical method and political
theories,
not his thoughts and the ladies.
If you're going to reduce a philosopher
down to seven minutes,
at least fill it with their major
contributions to the philosophical
world,
and sometimes they do worse than this in
this video,
along completely misunderstands the mind
body problem,
which is the question of how our mental
thought and consciousness controls our
physical body.
Completely missing this.
Instead,
alon explains that,
wow,
it's a darn shame that everyone judges
you so much on your luck's instead of
what's in your head.
The so called mind body problem is one
of the greatest and most quietly painful
conundrums in philosophy.
The problem is rooted in the fact that
in the eyes of other people,
all of us are automatically and stop and
associated with our bodies,
which includes,
of course our faces and this kind of
feel good.
Philosophy is more than just unhelpful.
It's counterproductive because it can
cause people to think that they possess
and understanding of philosophy when in
reality they have only been taught
shallow and disfigured elements of it.
Finally,
as if that wasn't all enough,
we come to the third and final problem
of the school of life.
They're hucksters and profiteers.
They established themselves as some sort
of guide of life and use that position
to sell merchandise that is priced so
high it borders on the insane.
How much would you say this imperfect
pot is worth?
It's literally a pot with blemishes on
it.
While it can be yours,
$75 or how about this?
Regular Candle?
$50,
but best of all and so telling of how
money grubbing this operation really is.
Is there an anticapitalist notebooks
which they shamelessly ironically sell
for the very pro capitalistic price of
$20.
How does some of this video,
I think alon his whole school of life as
best criticized through his own view of
business businesses should not.
He says so desires,
but instead cell needs,
and this is the crucial distinction he
makes between desires and needs.
A desire is what you feel like you want
at the moment,
and Anita is something that serves your
longterm wellbeing and I think you're
right alone,
so why in the world are you selling a
who should you be with card game for
$15,
I guess,
at that doesn't fall under the need
section for most people,
and the same is true for their actual
content in the same way at the school of
life should stop selling the desires of
the people.
Cheap,
watery self-help philosophy,
drivel that reinforces their belief
system and instead sell to the needs of
the people are real examination of what
the philosophers have been saying all
along and help explain how one best
ought to examine their lives because in
the end it's these true needs being met
that Plato and Aristotle would say
produces a life full of eudaimonia.
In other words,
a life well lived.